[Music]
some days my childhood feels
so very far away
and others i can almost see it
a magical land of my youth like a
beautiful dream
of when the whole world felt like a
promise
and the lessons that lay ahead yet
unseen
looking back i wish i'd listened
wish i'd watched more closely and
understood
but sometimes you can't see what you're
learning
until you come out the other side
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
mr
i've seen this contest humble even the
most seasoned warriors diana
i can do it just do your best
and remember greatness is not what you
think
pace yourself and watch
your time will come back
you will become all that your dreams and
more
and everything will be different
[Music]
those are cool i like those animal
prints
[Music]
diana one day you'll become all that you
dream of and
more and everything will be different
[Music]
this world is not yet ready
for all that you will do
you'll become a little
[Music]
[Music]
wonder woman 1984 in theaters and
streaming exclusively on hbo max
december 25th radiopg-13.
[Music]
you